you're facing a giant bowl of energy
packed carbon crunchies one spoonful two
three soon you're powered up by the
energy surge that comes from your meal
but how did that energy get into your
bowl energy exists in the form of sugars
made by the plant your cereal came from
like wheat or corn as you can see carbon
is the chemical backbone and plants get
their fix of it in the form of carbon
dioxide co2 from the air that we all
breathe
but how does a plants energy factory
housed in the stroma of the chloroplast
turn a1 carbon gas like co2 into a six
carbon solid like glucose
if you're thinking photosynthesis you're
right but photosynthesis is divided into
two steps the first which stores energy
from the Sun in the form of adenosine
triphosphate or ATP and the second the
calvin cycle that captures carbon and
turns it into sugar this second phase
represents one of nature's most
sustainable production lines and so with
that welcome to the world's most
miniscule Factory the starting materials
a mix of co2 molecules from the air and
preassembled molecules called ribulose
biphosphate or rubp each containing five
carbons the initiator and industrious
enzyme named Rubisco that welds one
carbon atom from a co2 molecule with the
rubp chain to build an initial six
carbon sequence that rapidly splits into
two shorter chains containing three
carbons each and called
phosphoglycerates or PGA's for short
enter ATP and another chemical called
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
phosphate or just nad pH ATP working
like a lubricant delivers energy while
NADPH of fixes one hydrogen to each of
the pga chains changing them into
molecules called glyceraldehyde 3
phosphates or g3ps glucose needs six
carbons to form made from two molecules
of g3p which incidentally have six
carbons between them so sugar has just
been manufactured right not quite the
Calvin cycle works like a sustainable
production line meaning that those
original ru bps that kicked things off
at the start need to be recreated by
reusing materials within the cycle now
but each rubp needs five carbons and
manufacturing glucose takes a whole six
something doesn't add up
the answer lies in one phenomenal fact
while we've been focusing on this single
production line five others have been
happening at the same time with six
conveyor belts moving in unison there
isn't just one carbon that gets
soldered to one are you BB chain but six
carbons soldered to six are you bps that
creates 12 g3p chains instead of just
two
meaning that all together thirty six
carbons exist the precise number needed
to manufacture sugar and rebuild those
are you bps of the twelve g3ps pulled
together to are siphoned off to form
that energy-rich six carbon glucose
chain the one fueling you via your
breakfast success but back on the
manufacturing line the byproducts of
this sugar production are swiftly
assembled to recreate those six rubp s
that requires 30 carbons the exact
number contained by the remaining 10
g3ps
now a molecular mix-and-match occurs two
of the g3ps are welded together forming
a six carbon sequence by adding a third
g3p a nine carbon chain is built the
first rubp made up of five carbons is
cast from this leaving four carbons
behind but there's no wastage here
those are soldered to a fourth g3p
molecule making a seven carbon chain
added to a fifth g3p molecule a 10
carbon chain is created enough now to
craft two more rubp s with three full
rubp s recreated from five of the ten
g3ps simply duplicating this process
will renew the six rubp chains needed to
restart the cycle again so the Calvin
cycle generates the precise number of
elements and processes required to keep
this biochemical production line turning
endlessly and it's just one of the
hundreds of cycles present in nature why
so many
because if biological production
processes were linear they wouldn't be
nearly as efficient or successful at
using energy to manufacture the
materials that nature relies upon like
sugar cycles create vital feedback loops
that repeatedly reuse and rebuild
ingredients crafting as much as possible
out of the planets available resources
such as that sugar built using raw
sunlight and carbon converted in plant
factories to become the energy that
powers you and
keeps the cycles revolving in your own
life